good evening ride fog are the livers in
duck fight these cost an absolute
fortune yeah 25 quid a pop so don't [ __ ]
it up this is Russell Russell Oh every
month good good
mark 1 good to see it don't mark 3
likewise good to see you ride this
fireman now you're my brigade mark 1
would you cut will you we famous for
beer stein Phyllis that lovely steak
yeah and I'll put together like a
roasted pepper it's [ __ ] disgusting
it's very quick very camp but you're a
bit of a domestic housewife did you make
your jam as well as all right keep that
one to yourself already yes six covers
table 12 yes six foie gras six beef six
very soon stop stop stop
so I pull out an order nicely at the end
of it say yes let's start again
katella's bollocks
I'll order six covers table 12 six five
six beef six berry soup let's do one
together first shall we yeah it's a for
us ninety percent fat yeah so don't even
the pan too long the whole [ __ ] thing
will disintegrate yes nice hot knife and
we use a hot knife to slice through
there very quickly so as not to break
fogger salt pepper nice upset of the
seasoning we lose as it rose so we're
gonna season it twice when we cease it
now and then once it's cooked yes we're
gonna season it again Paul goes on the
plate roll around the seasoning flat
side down first
yeah get the color in the foie gras yes
color is absolutely critical
it's nice crispy edge on the outside
there's nice thing sort of succulent
it's almost like a warm butter inside
for serving rhubarb yes with this boiler
because rhubarb is very sharp jars and
so it sort of helped to cut through the
richness of the foie gras now
that's just right it needs one minute on
the side there blue bar this time of
year it's absolute delicious
just nice zigzag rocket salad there yeah
now the foie gras is now rested and look
15 like that and every customer will be
paying okay can we put the foie gras in
the pattern together please it's not
smoking it's [ __ ] on up isn't it why
my man if I'm on that come on let's go
right three great season my boy wake up
please yes now don't burn the foie gras
because we burn the foie gras yeah it's
gonna be bitter [ __ ] colors car big
boy it's burn the man let's stop put it
down put it down put it down
hey guys I don't know it's got funny now
cuz I'm not [ __ ] laughing getting the
pin yes you [ __ ] [ __ ] hey guys
don't forget yes the best performer
brigade yeah come back yeah I'm not cook
here but they cook at Claridge's oh and
so far you're [ __ ] useless
[Applause]
[Music]
we really do enjoy to cook in it's sort
of part it's all about being in the
kitchen being together creating
something and all sitting down
afterwards and actually enjoying what
we've actually cooked you know we work
very well as a group but if we could
just to see how we actually work the
same when there's something else is
telling us what we got doing is
something I'm not used to doing I'll
cook for the whole watch temperatures
between ninety nine hundred degrees so
working in Gordon's kitchen doesn't
compare before bus I mean we are gonna
wipe the floor with this competition
this is a simple dish foie gras rhubarb
a salad you can make this at home
tomorrow night
even poppy and Ainsley Harriott couldn't
[ __ ] this one up yes
boy let's go for away now ma please yes
smoke up on you [ __ ] start address
sandwich come in good they take you play
with you let's go several 5jp
right we're ready the first three come
on let's go go go go
you eat Nadine oh my god there's nowhere
today that nothing
it looks really wrong a little bread hey
girls allowed on their foot you're aware
this is a Food Show right way and look
how skinny you are you don't need food
did you like foie gras did you like it
I'm a vegetarian
you're vegetarian it's not get a message
for the tears on the potatoes I'll come
and see you later yes
bloody hell it will be barb in a
Farquhar together to complement each
other and they were quite well actually
fabulous saying this substantial bit of
wah it makes it you know really
delicious or so much softness inside the
crispy outside results in yes yes 50
dinars I'm out of the 50 darkness and
how am I gonna pay for the foie gras
31 people will paying for the stuff 19 I
used to play for yeah that's great why
too long to petty too fatty
mm-hmm my liver which is full of words
yeah between 13 there's a delicious
delicacy that and in small quantities
yeah yeah yeah
christ almighty the main course is I
want fifty more pain we want it for the
ribeye yeah let's go it's unbelievable
next on the menu my lambs are about to
arrive or are they come out some of it
Janice reporter finding losses of the
plots
Girls Aloud tell me what they think of
that pop rival was it in the other
welcome back the f-word now five main
causes of butyl butter roasted rib eye
steak server good ass shows braised
carrots and sauteed new potatoes ribeye
this is the new Philip it's a chef's
dream it's got this wonderful casing of
fat separating the chain and the ribeye
so as it cooks
this fat just imparts more more flavor
it just melts in your mouth
delicious wrap nice and tight set that
in the fridge and will never come to cut
my portions they're exactly the same
size and more importantly I haven't
waste anything frig off chokes look
they're nice and firm it's really nice
sort of slurry axe throat nutty flavor
to them this time here perfectly cut off
the stalks remove leaves no one should
stop when you start seeing that really
nice light colored leaf inside take your
knife and then just peel down through
the stalk now that's your artichoke
prepped lemon that stops them from
oxidizing basically going Brown and just
cut them in half look at that that's the
beautiful celebration of spring
water lemons salt white wine vinegar
pepper olive oil
what let the knife do the work and look
at that that is beautiful hot pan
cooking the ribeye you've got to be
quick olive oil salt pepper get all that
seasoning soaking up now look at that
beautiful garlic crush rosemary into the
pan that's the noise you want to hear
that sizzling you ever got that get it
back out the pan for that color they're
absolutely phenomenal butter and this is
where it starts to take the steak to a
different level this butter is really
bringing out the texture and the flavor
of the meat out onto a plate and just
leave it to rest griddle olive oil
take out your artichoke salt and pepper
is the good okay perfect turn them over
artichokes off
call
and that is a dream come true rib of
beef griddled artichokes done yes
provides quite robust so it needs a
little color on there not [ __ ] black
in it but color is a big difference yeah
obviously the well-done ones are going
to take longer the rare I'm gonna take
less and the medium rare I'm gonna take
normal time right let's go yes what's
the mark for beef away listen to me two
medium one rare one medium rare
okay go for it you know forget the beef
cuts yes for B to medium one rare one
medium rare yes yes you're gonna get one
we're let's go one in here quickly let's
go get these underway right now just
remembering which ones yeah normal yeah
medium rare one takeout then you
continue cooking the two medium and that
one's on its own
yeah that's gonna take the longest then
after that what come down the ladder
yeah what comes next medium rare no well
done medium medium rare medium rare is
less cooked mediums more cooked with no
blood yeah good alright let's show it on
our way don't stop ticking loudly mark
warning you may want to turn your volume
down
here's Janet's reporter because of globe
flow BSC it's increasingly difficult to
work out what kind of meat we can eat
safely now I've come to rural France to
look at another kind of meat which we in
Britain are very very sentimental about
but we should consider eating it because
it's very good for you we Brits think of
horses as grand national winners or posh
pets but we're to blinkered to see it as
a fantastic tasting meat in France
they're really passionate about their
food and interestingly the only read me
that's going up in sales is horse meat
does Tony's running about the frame
so I've come to this horse farm and I've
seen that all the horses which are being
bred to be eaten a free-range they're
all healthy animals and they all seem
really happy thing I'm gonna choose this
one so I give this holster 9 yeah you
know it looks like Gordon
[Music]
I've chosen a horse it's now gonna be
slaughtered Gordon but it will be posted
to me in England after it's been
butchered nice later
I'm having a bit of a problem that it
sparked rant over comment
[Music]
although it's perfectly legal to eat
horsemeat over here in Britain just
about the only way to get followed of a
good bit of hall steak is to order it
from abroad roast bit what Gorger horse
meat has got no fat in 8 compared to
beef I was always told a small movie
timing boys is me to fry Gordon with
shallots garlic and thyme are you taste
it first
first of all perfectly cooked fantastic
it's tender firm hmm it's not stringy it
tastes like beef oh yes it may taste
like beef but horse meat contains half
the fat and ten times as much omega-3
[Music]
well I've been persuaded that horse meat
is really good for you and it's very
tasty and there lots of very very good
reasons why you should eat it so I've
decided to come to Cheltenham and see if
I can convert a few punters but it seems
there's a problem the place stepped in
and said that offering punters hosts
mate is a highly provocative act and may
cause a disturbance that's it you know
I'm not gonna let it hold me back to
keep PC plod happy I set up my barbecue
on some private property down the road
don't try this by day one - why is
because it is isn't it horse me for a
cautious start I've made my first
convert and then they kept on coming in
a world of mad cows and bird flu we
should be opening our eyes to new
possibilities I think that horse is a
really good source of protein and what
we should take seriously so I'm really
begging you out there to give it a go I
can't leave you did that you know that
anyway I have I can't just say it's the
first time for a long time that we can
completely agree together oh you should
never agree with you about anything no I
know but this holds yes Gordon yes
tasted really good
Gordon I can't believe you need to get
arrested at the racecourse they're
actually spooky enough Gordon most of
evil are tasted the horse mate yes at
the racecourse liked it it's slightly
gaming lean for you very packed in
protein so nice that we can agree on
something yes and you've had to wait
your 60 to do it
reminding me that I'm a [ __ ] patient
I just can't stop you saying the word 16
what's your problem my mum
[Applause]
clean the plates Martin pornstar saltine
good [ __ ] hey cousin gonna pay for it
yeah then you send on the dirty play
sorry big boy that's [ __ ] yeah I'll wash
them up but I didn't say they again so I
washed him up I didn't mark I set you up
with a perfectly clean kitchen a keg
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] me for big boy
yes are you always this [ __ ] chippy
oh yes chef yeah wine what's gonna try
to teach you something shoes no no no no
to get it right so you look good they
pay for [ __ ] dinner
you walk out on a high okay but I'm
buzzing the way that I don't like your
[ __ ] attitude
let's go right mark how for the poor
please it's ready to go video just how
long and they'll give me a time now a
minute I need to shut the [ __ ] up
let's go one minute to me I'll wait for
you I'm afraid I'm always medium rare
alo put more butter with the artichokes
yeah of course it doesn't finish it all
I'm going first
yes Hey look hello nicely colored yeah
we start with butter what happens are we
to understand something [ __ ] in here
don't get [ __ ] chipped with me I'm
here to help you guys look good yeah but
I can't talk to [ __ ] for at the same
time what I need right now is just a
little bit of puffiness yeah yeah so
yeah cool yeah a little bit yeah
super neat from these that's right thank
[ __ ] someone's thinking right let's go
that's amazing babe oh it's only been
down for five minutes really finish
their compliments to the chef
[ __ ] critical
[Music]
ladies ladies ladies ladies roaming
through a table dinner
[Laughter]
what's the secret barbecue spaghetti
bolognaise are you drinking tonight
yes I'm not drinking that means you have
a baby on the way I seriously like okay
girls with a bit of spider yeah and
Girls Aloud a little bit like me there's
always somebody out there knocking me
down whether it's the press radio you
name it they do it so I've got a little
test for you yeah okay
these are past quotes the individuals
have said about Girls Aloud tell me yeah
exactly we said it okay I've got a
Booker than this thick okay yeah I've
stopped laughter Michael Winner hey girl
yeah all the food critics up but I've
given up on them not my book this thick
so yours it feels there's only this
thing ok first water ok right who said
this and who are they talking about yes
I haven't resorted to wearing short
skirts and thanking a footballer get
into the charts now have I and he's on
me no it's Charlotte
yeah what'd you think when you pinned
down for god sakes she's picking on you
relax your hormones are changing relax
relax
okay next one who said this yes I knew
were they talked about that Geordie girl
she's crap she doesn't sing a note in
tune I'm amazed she got through I just
think he's too big garden what nobody
really wants to look like she'll they
just think they do
who said that Lou took the big chick
with a dick all water and pretty good to
see both you safely move a desert yes
yeah a wild berry soup with floating
islands yeah yeah think about a
fictional McDonald's would like it more
it's what why atomizer the medium to
well done and it was very rare baby pink
find a lot of me it's often really dry
that was really nice it's all in its own
juices so couldn't fault it at all okay
guys come on please let's go
results of the main course let's go how
many customers tonight we available
for main course within 37 people pain
37:13 arm pain yeah why 13 the main
reason is too long again too long yeah
not the right pre-salt for the mids so
again not the rights and the way these
been cooked sin to to read yeah
was it a sign not a Bible it's the first
time for these guys in a professional
kitchen for God's sake yeah I know
not bad yeah not perfect everything
decided not to pay for the main course
you know talk words that yeah is a joke
- Peter - time [ __ ] now make sure 50
out of 50 pay for the dessert yes next
on the menu Ronnie Corbett and his
missus have a domestic during the recipe
challenge Oh God check I told you not to
be indiscreet I knew he would worm
things I I've got a fast food solution
for every night of the week
and the brigade get behind Russell as he
makes the hardest call out of his career
one morning says I want mine me actually
at the moment
[Applause]
welcome back to the F word now Jesus
Jesus welcome back there were times
where pint-size recipe challenge the
rules are simple
a celebrity chooses their favorite dish
and I have to beat it with my version
right are you ready I'm ready
you know I hate losing I know there's
your camera ambience so what is the name
of your dish linguine with what linguine
with chili and crab Chilean crab just
very simple straightforward yes well can
you reach the word service my mother
I've been sabotage oh no come there were
two shallots here right and some red
chilies and some dried chili already I'm
two minutes in front yeah sorry yeah so
Ronnie's making a fresh linguine with
chili and crap sounds quite interesting
and I'm gonna do a very simple
straightforward tortellini basically
fresh roll out pasta
crab me in the center with some lemon
zest some basil salt pepper and a little
bit of ginger
Ronnie's using chili I'm using ginger
because I'm gonna beat it and I'm using
your fuchsia Raj oh sorry
have you actually ever caught crabs yes
I have whereabouts
pit whim shell a dyke and Strother the
whole other fight coach does that know
that you caught crabs I love the way you
stopped working you're so cool and calm
with what I'm looking at you like
doublespeak each other we're all [ __ ]
lahardee that's right yeah be here when
all nights how that's better
language Gordon please language Gordon
yes where is the darling heart book my
14 inch frying pan what you looking for
my man tell me was like big 14 inch
frying pan 14 inch frying pan hard to
hear we're having a bath in it oh there
we
now deliver food where did it come from
well my grandmother was a cook
housekeeper my father was a baker in
Edinburgh for 30 years committees so
it's a lot of cooking yeah in the family
and I'm now going to take the crabmeat
out come pick up for Ronnie Corbett this
is beautiful I mean this is lovely this
crab is running with moisture and
whiteness want to get on with these
linguine of crab and chili and right I'm
gonna start pulling out my pasta now the
secret behind the pasta it's give me a
really nice and thin to thick a pastor
of course the whole thing gets chewy
nice at all so Monte how are you doing
fine very well yes when you're at home
cooking in the countryside
does that ever help you in the kitchen
and it's very supportive in the kitchen
very sweet she opens the wine pours the
wine yeah what does eastenders rice
offers me a crisp
no and is a very good cook as well you
see yes
Jonathas can you ask Anne please quit it
through the kitchen I'm gonna sort of
ask her to help my total ease I'm
running behind no look yes my dad are
you going to chop you know am I totally
am is gonna show you me so the mix
inside okay there's with some lemon
basil fresh crabmeat
yeah and we're just gonna sort of bind
it together this little parcel okay
right yeah yeah only on parts only one
house I'll show you I could have told
you through right but I'm very easy so
you just pull that over there like that
push together and then from there yeah
you knit them together get all the air
out
yeah
very quickly look just from there left
to right right to left
oh that that is a clip no see I'm gonna
find a little hat darling let me do it
with you one little darling no look I
can do this one you see when you have
the cooking resin everything has to be
rushed and I can't bear that you see in
our kitchen it's all calm and I sit
there like this I go that's very good
this is a bit I don't like a grandma's
your finger then they're down there I'm
pushing push together like that hang on
it doesn't look like yours
left-right rights in there yes and then
you cut off Souza's that's fine you do
the rest because you show gonna lose
you're gonna lose this no no it's fine
I'll go straight to the staff canteen
it's fine because when we cook every
night yes seriously yes
what's the most romantic food romantic
he hates that sort of word it makes us
really embarrassed oh god check I told
you not to be indiscreet
you stole my basil no I'm not touchy a
bad joke no okay something's obliged the
tortellinis here got the fish to mars a
little bit of ginger Schlacht yes and a
little bit of vinaigrette mmm that's
just ready now little vinaigrette so
that looks nice
you don't excel like that will that [ __ ]
run outside of you can I catch one with
even the bowl honey what we're ready
right Jean Baptiste where's my little
French fighter pilot make sure you do
not get the mixed up thank yous come
back with a good news up
yes away let's go I leave the page Twala
hey hi how are you
so this is the first dish he's number
one and this is dish number two we know
what it is but do we have to guess we
don't have to taste time to introduce
the lamb to my own flock
the big days arrives my lambs are being
born and at six weeks are at last old
enough to travel up to London with their
mothers
[Music]
they'll be driven by May he owns the
ramen news i bread my lands from and
hates leaving his beloved flock well you
know what they say about Welshman listen
listen listen listen the Lambs are
arriving today yes yes so we gotta start
getting their new home ready for them
jack we're gonna have to get rid of that
goal put it down the side somewhere nice
[Music]
ready I had a sheep house constructed a
farmer made specification it's a luxury
home for the Sheep they're five minutes
away so they set up the fence yeah the
electric fence may also advise me to put
up an electric fence which is the normal
way for keeping sheep first the Sheep
had to get used to their new
surroundings especially the fence my
lambs are a crossbreed of Welsh mountain
and French Charolais so I've decided to
name them asked my favorite Welsh couple
Charlotte Church and Gavin Henson Tana
and I don't want our kids growing up
into total urban softest we feel it's
important that they hear the full story
of the Lambs birth it's not always
straightforward as you think it is
delivering Lambs okay I press play
please make six weeks earlier Charlotte
was born okay but there was a big
problem with the birth of my second lamb
no it's not a free sugar he's live at
the moment but he won't live for long
he's just developed a big belly yes some
of them do not very often but some of
them do
minutes later the lamb died so Mesa late
is an orphan for the you to foster
instead just look at the smell the same
[Music]
and she'll think it does it hurt all and
she will she won't be like that her lamb
is actually died just put her in front
of it
Gavin's fostered so we're gonna look
after them and give them some special
love yes special TLC tender loving care
it's already clear that raising my own
sheep is gonna make keeping pigs look
easy
[Music]
gotta get these 50 customers paying for
this [ __ ] desert the lemon juice
inside stabilizes the egg white so it
gives it some strength makes it look
nice and firm yeah okay stiff peak yeah
nice tippy separate the two teams yes
let's get cracking yes type of desserts
are very soon with champagne on floating
islands
[Music]
this time of year absolutely phenomenal
wonderful berries it's thickened with
natural Greek yogurt and then finish
with the most amazing champagne milk
this is a little bit of magic
the fresh vanilla seed flatten it down
all the way open it up scrape out the
seeds in whisk in the vanilla mint gives
a really nice sort of fresh and even
more fragrant perfume to the meringue
bring that to the ball
the meringue three egg whites make sure
there's no yolk in the egg white
whatsoever and whip up the egg white
lemon squeeze the lemon juice in sugar
whack it up full blast
look these wonderful nice rich meringue
moves come with the ball get your spoon
in the egg white and then with another
spoon pour now then into the milk when
you spoon the milk over the meringue it
stops them from sticking together and
just leave them poaching there on the
side for about four or five minutes
the most exciting thing about making
this soup it's like the ultimate
smoothie blackberries blue
raspberries red cones and the secrets
allow the fruit to go overripe so the
flavour is extraordinary mint
yogurt cream
and this is where it starts to get
really exciting champagne off 300
million okay now it's [ __ ] everywhere
ready steady [ __ ] who was that still use
champagne sparkling wine two tablespoons
of sugar and that gets rid of that sort
of very strong acidity flavour lid on
blitz
pour into your bowl beautiful color
carefully lift out your meringue and
just sit on top of the suit and their
summer berry and champagne soup with
floating islands done mmm [ __ ] me
it smells delicious for soup marker mark
Ross the man for Superboy yeah tables
one Cheryl - I mean Suzie egg white
going there will cool it down to bring
you back up again yes more champagne it
[Music]
it must been the most embarrassing or
peculiar scenario you've been on a call
out to a girl on a guy they claim that
they claim that they wasn't boyfriend
and girlfriend but they it was actually
handcuffed together to have clothes on
well she had that dressing gown on
instead it [ __ ] up standing there
proud very happy with yourself
we did have to actually cut cut and pray
we obviously go to more important things
than that
bloody hope so christ almighty jesus
christ almighty
by TC yep I major because I recognized
it done it sir last these guys are
realizing that great food can still be
fast food as Brits were at the longest
house in Europe and we also become a
nation of long-distance commuters not
good
well I don't care how many hours a week
you're pushing paper there's no excuse
not to cook I'm making it my business to
prove that fast food can still mean good
food I'm off to meet a hard-working
commuting couple who eat packaged salads
every night so I got having about 7:30
and Louise because she's got a new job
probably gets back a little bit later
say about 8 o'clock we don't really know
how to put simple things together so we
always revert back to our favourite
choice which is just got the salads in
with Louise working over 12 hours a day
it's not exactly a recipe for marital
bliss it is starting to annoy me at the
moment getting home and finding that
he's sitting on the sofa eating his
salads and that he hasn't actually been
into the kitchen and and prepared
anything
[Music]
so I've come to show Paul how to make
five fast simple recipes each of which
takes less than half an hour Molly the
Friday is the problem yeah yes yeah I've
got five ingredients okay basically
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
now okay this is not the Boreas two and
half hours in the kitchen this is quick
fast food that can be done within sort
of eight to twelve minutes max okay
first ingredient eggs bacon please don't
cheat and phase we little salad sounds
good okay bacon
[Music]
how many times have you cooked for her
no you've never cook for your wife and
18 months no I'm surprised you're still
here right and Madam's on the way home
okay yeah and she's gonna be happy
I'm telling you why
gratefully number two it's a certified
chicken and it's finished with really
nice egg noodles first by your chopped
vegetables
[Music]
then cook your chicken in a hot wok cook
your noodles in boiling water and then
add we go step further it'll be the
fresh ginger look with fresh coriander
but get the basics right first mm-hmm
it's so healthy the things is so simple
that you've not to make it right rescue
number three linguine Puttanesca this is
a classic Italian sauce made with garlic
tomatoes and anchovies
[Music]
Plus shallots some chili a handful of
capers olives and basil
I'm ashamed to say that my grandma is
Italian if she said she spent most of
her life in the kitchen Italian grandma
yeah device that she'd be mortified
[Music]
right rescue number four get half the
perfect steak sandwich time with
Phillips take a meal on its own
[Music]
do you think she'll be impressed I think
she'll be overboard with it to be honest
we get fast food doesn't need to be long
does it no add olive oil and thyme to
you chip matter how much you spent on
salads a week roughly fifty quid a week
yeah 200 Panama
yeah tuna half grands a year on salads
yeah yes yes that's pathetic
[Music]
rescue number five parrot salmon with a
fresh mint pea puree light mint fresh
frozen peas
so doesn't have to be all projects we've
kept it on frozen stuff is why you
suppose people would say yeah just
season it salt and pepper okay I want to
cook it skin side down so why did you do
that
we leave the skin on there okay to
prevent it from going dry
[Music]
and then the pea puree
we've got a solution for Monday
Wednesday Thursday Friday yes
no more [ __ ] salads yes you couldn't
teach Paul had to do ironing and
cleaning as welcome you next on the menu
Abe who comes out top in the recipe
challenge Russell get the answer he's
looking for
so do you marry me
[Laughter]
yeah let's fight spicy flavor I think
it's quite light okay good and they were
happy very happy yes obviously one clear
winner one very clear winner yes good
okay it's 4 to 1 4 to 1 of course useful
to what I'm surprised it's not five
nails yeah it's four to one anyway there
it is
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you oh my god cried john baptiste
come back two seconds don't just
disappear
what do they say um the the yours where
the pastor was to thinking the poster
was what yeah to play click a bit to
identify and because you're happy oh yes
I've been tagged it was there's a bite
to it little bit I got beaten yeah Oh
God by somebody half more yeah we're
gonna win oh thank you very much what is
your job isn't at risk
yeah but I'll give you a favor yes yeah
I'm [ __ ] off out Mike
[Music]
yes yeah yes yes okay right nice and
quiet something major going on the
moment yeah Susie I'm so sorry darling
what you sleeping no you weren't and
this club rooms are here just calling
from the air forward kitchen and
Russell's had the most amazing day
there's something there's something
something he's been dying to a shoot and
it's taking this moment to realize that
he's been wasting time the last five
years okay right Russell I want you to
shout down the phone do your beloved
Suzy those can you meet someone says I'm
on my knee actually at the moment so do
you marry me
don't go through so says I'm not joking
I'm singing understanding here little
ads are behind me loose ideas Golden's
drag down me so they start far too long
now
please say yes
[Applause]
look beautiful to say congratulations
[Applause]
hey listen I'm so happy for you hey
listen to me the best thing I ever did
was get married
results of the desserts okay up this yep
hopefully good news yes I'm Betty one
out of fifty thousand thirty seven out
of fifty four main yes yeah how many
customers we paying yes come on JP the
desserts bouquet we having tonight
underneath thirty-eight to be last
week's brigade come on twenty-eight Oh
God too long again I feel too bland
to burn is a people ripe summer berry
soup floating islands but that's what
champagne that's a grand total of 96 yes
out of a hundred and fifty yeah sadly
you'll not becoming bearish rubbish
maybe looking for a pie for dinner okay
good luck with the wedding yes how's a
drink she'll stop your knickers yeah
lovely
Fanny I've got it